I'm joined today by Daniel Willingham
who is a psychologist at the University
of Virginia where he is a professor in
the Department of Psychology his
research focuses on the applications of
findings from cognitive psychology and
neuroscience to K through 12 education
it's so great to speak to you I recently
read a very interesting article which
discussed the idea of whether listening
to an audio book rather than reading it
in the traditional sense is in any way
cheating and I think to have this
conversation we first sort of have to
decide what would count as cheating so
what what do people generally mean when
they say is it cheating it's a great
question because I feel like when you
say listening to an audio book is in
some sense cheating very few people say
what what are you talking about what
does that even mean so everyone has some
intuitive sense of what's meant by that
but it's not quite as obvious when you
unpack it what what I take it to mean
what I take cheating to mean is cheating
is when you get some sort of a resource
you get some sort of a goodie even
though you haven't done the work that is
supposed to be done in order to get
access to that goodie so it feels like
that what people are saying is listening
to an audiobook is in some way easier
and therefore you're getting the
pleasure of having reading the book or
also possibly the credit of having read
the book hmm without credit sort of
among your peers yet to say yes I read
that book without having put the work in
I believe that what you mentioned last
there the sort of credit in society is
really the aspect of it that that people
are mostly referring to because when I
think about it if you when we when we
talk about cheating the questions I
would have if you listen to an audio
book are how is your level of
comprehension affected by having
listened to it rather than having read
it we know about the very positive
effect on vocabulary that regular
reading has do you get the same benefit
from listening to the book or not so
let's start first there with with that
what does research tell us about
the benefits of reading a book in
written form versus listening to it so
if there is someone who is a very fluent
decoder is the is the lingo which means
that decoding is the process of looking
at print on the page and sort of
sounding it out in your mind getting
words from print that's on the page
that's decoding so if you're very fluent
at that you're very experienced in other
words if you're an adult a typical adult
reader there's enormous overlap between
reading something in print on the page
and listening to it they're not
identical processes but most of what
most of the language processing that
your mind does when you're reading is
really piggybacking on language
processes that are used in conversation
and just sort of normal oral language
okay so there are differences but lots
of overlap okay
so what do we know then about areas
where the sort of net effect on an
individual from listening listening to
an audio book versus reading it might
differ so and again a lot of this is
less about formal experiments that have
been done on this and more sort of
things that we know about reading so you
can sort of reason where things would be
different one way in which listening to
an audio book is going to be different
is that you get you the person who's
reading it provides what's called
prosody prosody is the sort of melody of
speech and prosody carries information
so for example if I said to you hey what
a great party this is that's one thing
whereas if I say oh what a great party
this is right the difference between
sarcasm and sincerity in that case is a
hundred percent based on prosody it's
the pacing of which words I emphasize
and so on now that's invisible on the
page right and prosody actually matters
to how we understand speech and and even
some sort of low-level processes like
figuring out which is what what's the
subject of the sentence what's the verb
and the sentence and so forth so that's
a notable difference now how frequently
does that make a real importance of
financial difference in comprehension
the fact that in listening you get
prosody in reading you have to provide
it yourself the answer to that is not
known it's probably not that often I
mean the extreme version that I can
imagine is something like reading a
Shakespearean play where for you know
Americans living today a Shakespearean
English is really a different dialect of
English and so it's a struggle for us to
piece it together so they're having that
extra cue would help a lot if you're
reading verses listening to the latest
Dan Brown thriller Pross he's probably
not going to make such a big difference
what do we know if anything and or what
might your speculation be depending on
what the answer is to the first part
when it comes to probably more
nonfiction than fiction what do we know
or could we expect about the long-term
retention of material in terms of
listening to a nonfiction book be it a
biography or a science book or whatever
versus reading it writes a great
question and I would say if
comprehension is the same then you would
expect the retention to be comparable so
I think here we get to the other
difference when you mention nonfiction I
think we get to another important
difference between listening to a book
and reading a book which is pacing when
I'm reading from print pacing is
completely under my own control whereas
when I'm listening sort of in principle
sure I guess I can go you know stop the
CD and go back and listen to something
again but I'm probably a whole lot less
likely to do that than I would be in
print and we know when people are
reading print eye movements actually a
substantial proportion of them something
like maybe 10 15 percent are actually
backward eye movements where you're
going back in to the beginning of a
sentence or an earlier part of a
sentence to reread something those you
don't even notice but of course you very
much feel it when you sort of get to the
bottom of page and you suddenly say gosh
I just realized I don't I don't really
understand what I've been reading let me
let me go back a little bit and try
again so this is where something like
listening to a textbook that's full of
new and for me
that's going to be pretty complex we
would expect that to be pretty difficult
and probably again this is less about
retention and more about online
comprehension that's going to be
compromised bottom line when we get back
to this idea of the concept of cheating
with audio books is there any way in
which we can say that there is any
advantage other than maybe that you
could listen to an audio book more
quickly than you would read it is there
anything else that we could call an
advantage of or or anything that could
even remotely approach what we would
call cheating by listening the only
advantage and I think this gets back to
what we were saying at that at the top
of our discussion the only way I think
you could call it an advantage is that
it feels like it's easier to multitask
and when you're listening you mentioned
that listening would be faster less what
is actually slower is that right I mean
it does make sense because your internal
dialogue may and you're sort of silent
reading voice may actually be faster
than the speed at which an audio book is
recorded absolutely for most people it
is and you can try this yourself again
if you're if you're fluent decoder and
you're a typical adult reader you will
read faster than you can then you can
speak so that's actually not an
advantage but it does feel like it's
easier to do something else I can listen
to an audio book in the car I can listen
to an audio book when I'm doing dishes
or something like that
and that may in principle I guess you
can multitask while you're reading a
print book too I mean you and I could be
having a conversation and I'm sort of
trying to read a print book at the same
time people tend not to do that right so
yeah probably is a difference in how
readily you can multitask and that may
be the the sense in which people feel
like it's cheating it's like gosh you
and I are in this book club and I read
the paper version and I had to carve out
time to make sure that I could get to it
and so on and now I find out you were
doing the audiobook shucks I could have
been in my car listening to the
audiobook and and I would have saved
myself some time so that may be
important in the cheating this idea of
how easily you can multitask well when I
think about it and get back to the end
I'm convinced that the entire cheating
aspect is more social stigma and the the
prototypical book club is exactly where
I would think about it where you come in
and you say oh you know I didn't get my
reading done this week on either to die
and then someone says oh I'm done with
the book because I've just been
listening to it on the way to and from
work that person or for better or worse
is going to be critique critiqued by
someone as having taken a shortcut
aren't they I think that's right and
again I have nothing to go on here but
anecdote but I'll tell you since I wrote
that piece about audiobooks and cheating
lots of people have emailed and called
me and many of them have brought up book
clubs in particular as the place that I
get attacked for having listened to a
book absolutely so there you go
absolutely fascinating Daniel Willingham
I believe that this will also become
more of an issue as we move forward in
terms of technology and and more
technological usage of how people learn
the idea of sped up recordings and the
idea of being able to condense
I know people who listen to podcasts and
they listen to them at 2x speed and they
say you know I'm finding I'm getting 90%
of what I would get but I'm listening in
half the time I believe this will have
more implications in the next five years
that's that's a really interesting
observation my sense is the same as
yours and let me just encourage all of
your listeners and viewers of this video
you should not only watch this in real
time but you should watch it several
times absolutely no doubt about it all
right professor of psychology Daniel
Willingham thank you so much for talking
to me today my pleasure